[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 que vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la suspension
de toutes les rotations militaire de la
minustah au mali annonce de vama crosse
et le nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère des soldats ivoiriens arrêtés le
10 juillet au mali toujours détenu par
le pouvoir malien qui les considèrent
comme des mercenaires ce qu abidjan
dément des explications à suivre dans
cette édition
l'armée française en question au niger
les ministres français des armées et des
affaires étrangères sont à niamey et ils
vont rencontrer le président bazoum pour
une réorganisation de l'opération barkan
désormais centré sur le pays
on les appelle les trois grands cela
fait plusieurs décennies qu'il préside à
la destinée de la côte d'ivoire dix ans
après leur dernière rencontre alassane
ouattara henri konan bédié laurent
gbagbo sont revit nous irons sur place
on passe au mali où il ya de nouveaux
rebondissements dans la sphère des
soldats ivoiriens arrêtés le 10 juillet
bamako les détient toujours et les
considèrent comme des mercenaires ce qu
abidjan dément disant qu'il s'agit de
soldats militaires en soutien à la
mission des nations unies le
gouvernement malien a annoncé la
suspension de toutes les rotations
militaire de la minustah la mission des
nations unies déployée au mali les
explications avec camille nédélec
l'onu n'est plus la bienvenue la junte
militaire a suspendu les rotations des
casques bleus au mali invoquant des
préoccupations d'ordre de la sécurité
nationale la junte a déclaré que la
suspension durera jusqu'à la tenue d'une
réunion pour coordonner et réglementer
le mouvement du personnel minus ment sur
son territoire il ya quelques jours les
militaires ont arrêté 49 soldats
ivoiriens qui selon eux seraient des
mercenaires mais la côte d'ivoire
affirme que ce sont des prestataires de
l'onu des soi-disant nation supporter
element pour soutenir ces deux comtés
gens qui se trouvent à la lumière à led
à dire la compagnie de mopti et le
bataillon de toutous donc pour soutenir
ces deux détachements a eu besoin après
autorisation de l'onu de sue et à
l'issue d'un protocole d'accord avec la
société sas a eu besoin d'installer une
et ce en anglais c'est la sonas pour
qu'ils m'aident à dire les éléments de
soutien dont a eu besoin d'un set et
bien cela à part ma peau compte tenu du
fait que c'est la capitale docker comme
une base logistique avancée la minustah
est l'une des plus grandes opérations de
l'onu avec environ 14000 personnes
venant de dizaines de pays lancée en
2013 cette mission combat les
djihadistes dans le pays en janvier
dernier le mali avait déjà suspendu ses
opérations aériennes pendant plusieurs
jours la mission a été renouvelé en juin
mais le texte du mandat ne fait aucune
mention du statut des sous traitants de
l'onu c'est que la déprime 1
ce cas intéressante les différentes
missions a été planifiée et conduite
sans forcément
que le mali soit effectivement événement
impliqués mais les amplis
on observe un regain d'intérêt manifesté
par l'élite militaire au pouvoir les
quel intérêt aurait purement le contrôle
tout c'est que c'est pas sur le
territoire que tous les acteurs évoluent
désormais sous les dictats de l'état
central et les casques bleus de l'onu
actuellement mission mali sont
maintenant bloqués dans le pays suite à
cette suspension
les nations unies appelle bamako a
trouvé une solution de toute urgence
au niger voisin les ministres français
des armées des affaires étrangères sont
arrivées ce vendredi ils
s'entretiendront avec le président
bazoum sur la réorganisation de
l'opération barkan désormais concentrer
sur le pays la correspondance d'harold
gérard
le président nigérien mohamed bazoum
aura donc passé sa semaine une fois de
plus à parler de sécurité d'abord un
premier accord a été signé lundi entre
le niger et le bénin le pays qui bordent
le niger par le sud craint de voir ce
exporter une partie des violences
djihadistes qui se concentre dans la
zone des trois frontières et bien sur
son territoire le ministre de la défense
béninois l'a annoncé lundi le bénin doit
tirer profit de l'expérience du niger en
matière de lutte contre le djihadisme
mohamed bazoum a également rencontré ce
mercredi son homologue tchadien à
n'djamena les deux hommes sont tombés
d'accord il ne souhaite en aucun cas
laisser tomber la force conjointe anti
djihadistes affiliés au g5 selle malgré
la sortie du mali le niger et le tchad
ont signé un accord de coopération
sécuritaire dont pour l'instant aucun
élément n'a filtré
la mort de l'opération takouba mais
aussi de l'opération par cannes sur le
sol malien laisse entrevoir une très
faible viabilité de cette force
conjointe affiliés au g5 celle sans le
mali mais les deux hommes continuent d'y
croire demain nous devrions avoir plus
de détails sur le redéploiement de
l'armée française à travers cette
opération barkan sur le sol ni rien ce
que nous savons pour l'instant c'est
qu'au moins deux postes militaires côté
nigérien situé à la frontière entre le
niger et le mali sont en train d'être
renforcé et tout cela avec l'appui de
l'opération barkan
en guinée les habitants de conakry sont
obligés de vivre avec des ordures depuis
quelques jours les rues de la capitale
guinéenne ont atteint un niveau
d'insalubrité sans précédent face à la
situation le président de la transition
a demandé ce jeudi à tous les ministres
de descendre dans la rue pour assainir
la ville des explications avec malik
diakité notre correspondant à conakry
depuis près de deux semaines les camions
de ramassage d'ordures ne sillonnent
plus les différents quartiers de la
ville l'unicode des chargeurs de la
capitale a atteint sa capacité maximale
résultat les rues de conakry sont
envahies d'ordures en tout genre les
passants sont obligés d'en tomber l'aide
des prix et de supporter les odeurs une
situation devenue insupportable pour ses
habitants de conakry à nous fatiguer les
yeux fatigués parce que ça fait mais
comme ça ne doit pas ramassées
aujourd'hui on a tort fait aux donateurs
parce que c'est vraiment c'est très
fatigant
quand on passe à chaque jour nous sommes
dans l'essor du moment nous sommes
allergiques à ça et nous demande
effectivement au bout le manteau
dépendance à responsabilités pour mettre
afin fectivement à 7 attendus dont la
population souffre avec face à ce
ras-le-bol généralisé le président de la
transition guinéenne le colonel mamadou
doumbouya à écourter sujet dit le
conseil hebdomadaire des ministres pour
faire face à la situation
ce samedi chef de l'état nous sommes
aujourd'hui tous les ministres est parti
dans les communes de conakry pour
ramasser les ordures on a besoin de
sensibiliser largement la population
parce que déjà on n'a même pas un
mécanisme de tri des ordures aux métaux
dans la même poubelle et ce qui n'est
pas du tout normal nous devons largement
sensibilisé la population en guinée la
gestion des déchets est un véritable
casse-tête la politique d'assainissement
ne sut pas le rythme de l'accroissement
de la population l'unique de charger de
la capitale a été aménagé alors que
conakry comptait moins de 1 million de
personnes aujourd'hui la même des
charges est censé recueillir les déchets
de 4 millions personne
ils sont omniprésents dans l'histoire
politique ivoirienne depuis plusieurs
décennies mais leurs rencontres
officielles sont rares alassane ouattara
henri konan bédié laurent gbagbo dit les
trois grands se sont revus après 10 ans
objectif faire avancer la réconciliation
après les crises postélectorales 2010
2011 mais aussi préparer les prochains
scrutins notre correspondant samuel
bernard y était
cette rencontre attendue et symbolique
est le signe d'une décrispation du
climat politique ivoirien la dernière
rencontre entre les trois hommes date de
2010 12 ans donc et 12 ans après
l'objectif pour les trois hommes qui
dominent la vie politique ivoirienne
depuis les années 90 c'est ce soir de
montrer que les crises politiques aussi
bien celles de 2011 que de 2020 sont
derrière eux une rencontre qui est l'une
des recommandations du dialogue
politique qui s'est tenu entre eux donc
le gouvernement et l'opposition de
décembre 2021 à mars 2022 alors ce soir
l'enjeu pour henri konan-bédié laurent
gbagbo ce sera de pousser un certain
nombre de questions comme la retouche de
la carte électorale la réforme de la
commission électorale indépendante et en
particulier pour laurent gbagbo la
libération des prisonniers politiques
alors la réunion s'est tenue à huis clos
mais on peut évidemment imaginer qu'ils
auront évoquée surtout le le cadre de la
prochaine élection présidentielle de
2025 dont une question qui est dans tous
les esprits alors qu'une loi a été
déposée à l'assemblée nationale cette
année pour limiter l'âge légal des
candidats à cette élection loi qui
écarterait donc la possibilité de voir
des trois hommes se représenter
c'est une anomalie qui n'est pas rare
sur le continent mais toujours
stupéfiante l'afrique produit 60% du
cacao dans le monde pourtant les
producteurs ne perçoivent que 5% des
revenus générés d'une manne colossale
estimée à plus de 120 milliards de
dollars pour remédier à cette inégalité
une initiative a été mise en place en
2010 9 entre la côte d'ivoire et le
ghana la semaine dernière un accord a
été signé afin de donner un second
souffle un préaccord mise à mal par la
crise pour en parler on retrouve
l'architecte de cette réunion au sommet
avec 16 industrielle en direct depuis
accra au ghana alex assanvo merci vous
êtes secrétaire exécutif de l'initiative
cacao côte d'ivoire ghana merci à nous
rejoindre et dites nous que va changer
cet accord sachant que depuis trois ans
malgré le premier accord les revenus des
planteurs n'ont pas augmenté
bonjour madame tout d'abord je vous
remercie en effet je pense que c'est une
déception mais de notre côté nous avons
aujourd'hui trois éléments qui jouent en
faveur d'un changement le premier c'est
que nous avons une initiative des deux
pays qui est fonctionnel qui existent et
qui a une équipe dont moi-même qui
dirige les équipes travaillant en
coordination avec les pays donc cela a
été fait depuis août 2000 21 ce qui veut
dire ya presqu'un an que nous sommes au
travail et deuxième point nous avons un
environnement législatif de pression des
gouvernements européens par exemple et
même d'autres gouvernements qui ont tous
le constat qu'il n'est pas possible
d'arriver un cadre durable de neuilly
n'est pas possible de pouvoir demander
certaines choses aux planteurs sans
qu'on puisse résoudre la crise
économique et le troisième point c'est
que cet accord qui a été mis en place
sous la houlette de l'initiative cacao
côte d'ivoire ghana est en fait un cadre
un cadre qui inclut un suivi et
évaluation des actions et ce cadre là va
nous permettre de pouvoir mesurer les
activités de chacun les engagements des
entreprises et pouvoir porter aussi
globalement mais aussi pour les actions
alors dis ça mais c'est toujours
beaucoup nous alors on est pris par le
temps mais dites nous comment vous
expliquez que les 120 milliards de
revenus que génèrent l'industrie du
cacao seuls 5 % reviennent finalement
aux planteurs africain
c'est très simple vous savez le cacao
historiquement a été mis en place comme
un secteur d'approvisionnement donc
aujourd'hui
ce cette dissolution de la valeur donc
très démesuré montre en fait qu'il ya
des changements à faire et on le voit
aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire au ghana
nous avons une transformation beaucoup
plus élevé mais le grand problème c'est
la consommation la consommation n'est
pas en afrique la consommation se fait
en occident en europe aux etats-unis et
ailleurs donc pour nous l'objectif n'est
pas de juste regarder comment consommer
plus mais c'est comment faire partir de
cette chaîne de valeur et donc
aujourd'hui c'est regarder les aspects
positifs du cacao donc on parle du
cosmétique on parle de valeurs
nutritives oui je suis attendu qu'à côté
peut-être que la question est justement
la plus largement est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un problème de transformation du cacao
sur place qui est aujourd'hui largement
calibré pour l'industrie du chocolat en
fait est que devraient faire les pays
producteurs et autres industriels
africains
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
l'objectif pour nous c'est de regarder
comment créer un nouveau marché un
nouveau marché qui va prendre en baisse
et les nouvelles valeurs de ce cacao
tout en gardant le chocolat mais aussi
nous avons nous regardons ces deux
choses qui sont comment ramener la
transformation localement dans la région
donc sur le continent donc vous savez il
ya aujourd'hui l'initiative de l'union
africaine qui est la zélée coeur qui est
la zone de libre échange du continent
africain qui va nous permettre de
pouvoir créer
des marchés et des transformations et
d'industrie locale compétitive et
l'objectif c'est de rendre le cacao et
sa transformation beaucoup plus
attractive que qu'à l'étranger mr simon
travaillant dessus merci merci
infiniment alex à 100 de vos d'avoir été
l'invitée du journal de l'afrique c'est
ainsi que nous refermons ce journal
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis et
de partout d'âcre à abidjan en passant
par bamako reste avec nous car
l'activité continué sur france musique
[Musique]